* Arabische Klänge *
Jemen, das ärmste Land
der gesamten arabischen Welt.
Wie geht es dir und Mohammed?
Wie geht es Mohammed?
Kann ich ihn untersuchen?
Über den Krieg im Jemen
erfahren wir im Westen kaum etwas.
Fast ein Jahr hat es gedauert,
bis wir als SRF-Korrespondenten alle
Bewilligungen hatten, um hinzufahren.
Es geht um Macht und um Öl,
um lokale Identitäten,
es spielt der Konflikt zwischen
dem sunnitischen Saudi-Arabien
und dem schiitischen Iran -
in einem Land, das spätestens mit
dem gescheiterten Arabischen Frühling
in die Anarchie abgeglitten ist.
Das ist, weil er unterernährt ist.
Nicht wegen trockener Haut.
Im Jemen herrscht Krieg - und
es herrschen unzählige Kleinkriege.
* Funkgespräch auf Arabisch *
Und es herrscht
eine unerträgliche Armut.
Das meiste, das wir bräuchten,
um ihn zu untersuchen, fehlt leider.
Der Präsident des Internationalen
Komitees vom Roten Kreuz
sagt über den Jemen,
eine solche Armut habe nicht einmal
der Krieg in Syrien
oder im Irak ausgelöst.
Wir beginnen unsere Reise
in diesen vergessenen Krieg dort,
wo die Folgen am deutlichsten sind:
in einem Spital.
Wir besuchen das Al-Sadaqa-Spital,
das grösste öffentliche Spital
in Aden,
der Hafenstadt
ganz an der Südspitze des Jemen.
Immer dabei: unsere Leibwächter,
ohne die wir
als ausländisches Fernsehteam
keinen Schritt machen könnten.
In den Gängen des Spitals:
Dutzende Mütter mit ihren Kindern.
In einem der Zimmer:
ein kleines Baby.
Mohammed ist drei Monate alt.
In wenigen Tagen
wird er vier Monate alt sein.
Er wiegt 2,9 kg.
Dabei sollte er 5 oder 6 kg wiegen.
Mohammed
hat einen gespaltenen Gaumen.
Dadurch
kann er kaum Nahrung aufnehmen.
Ich möchte ihn stillen,
aber es geht nicht.
Salam alaikum.
Eine Ärztin kommt ins Zimmer.
Die meisten Ärzte hier haben seit
Monaten kein Gehalt mehr bekommen.
Wer arbeiten kommt,
tut dies oft freiwillig.
Dieser kleine Junge
ist drei Monate alt.
Er hat seit der Geburt
einen gespaltenen Gaumen
sowie doppelt gespaltene Lippen.
Deswegen konnte der Kleine
nicht so viel Nahrung aufnehmen,
wie ein Kind aufnehmen sollte.
Deswegen wird er entweder sterben
oder lebenslang Probleme haben.
Starke Unterernährung
ist im Jemen sehr verbreitet.
Allein in diesem Spital
haben wir täglich bis zu fünf
oder sechs neue Patienten.
Der Hauptgrund für Unterernährung
ist die Armut.
Viele sind zu arm,
um sich genügend Nahrung zu kaufen.
Und wir hier im Spital
können kaum etwas tun.
Mohammed ist nicht unterernährt,
weil es im Jemen
nicht genügend Nahrung gibt.
Er ist unterernährt, weil er
mit einer Gaumenspalte zur Welt kam.
Diese Fehlbildung wird normalerweise
operiert. Nicht so im Jemen.
Kein einziges Spital
ist hier derzeit in der Lage,
diese Operation durchzuführen.
Der Krieg zwischen der
von Saudi-Arabien geführten Koalition
gegen die vom Iran
unterstützten Huthi
ist inzwischen
ein ganzes Stück von Aden entfernt.
Die Frontlinie verläuft heute
knapp 300 km weiter nördlich.
Auf unserem Weg entlang der
jemenitischen Küste Richtung Front
sind die Spuren des Krieges
allgegenwärtig.
* Spannende arabische Klänge *
Nach 6 Std. Fahrt
plötzlich ein grosser Checkpoint.
* Funkspruch auf Arabisch *
Die Kämpfer am Checkpoint
sind freundlich, aber auch skeptisch.
Wir werden
erst einmal zur Seite gebeten.
Während die lokalen Kommandeure
unsere Bewilligungen prüfen,
steigen hinter ihnen Kämpfer in
ihren gepanzerten Truppentransporter.
Eine Uniform trägt hier keiner.
Manche der Männer
scheinen sehr jung zu sein.
Endlich dürfen auch wir weiterfahren.
Wir gelangen nach Mokka,
einer Kleinstadt
gut 250 km nördlich von Aden.
Am Rande der Stadt:
die Kommandobasis der Koalition.
Der Krieg im Jemen geht eigentlich
zurück bis ins Jahr 1990.
Damals hatten sich die
zuvor geteilten Nord- und Südjemen
wiedervereinigt.
Doch anstatt zusammenzuwachsen,
begann die Zentralregierung in Sanaa,
alte Machtstrukturen zu zerstören
und lukrative Einnahmequellen wie Öl
an sich zu reissen.
Als im Zuge des Arabischen Frühlings
Langzeitherrscher Ali Abdullah Salih
von seiner Machtposition
verjagt wurde,
eskalierte der Machtkampf
um die Kontrolle des Staatsapparates
und damit der Einnahmequellen.
Das sind die eigentlichen Gründe
dieses Krieges.
Rund um den Stützpunkt
herrscht rege Aktivität.
Doch uns wollen die Kommandeure der
Koalition offenbar nicht empfangen.
Wir beschliessen,
weiter ins Städtchen hineinzufahren.
Auch hier sind die Spuren des Krieges
unübersehbar.
Ausländische Soldaten der Koalition,
wie diese aus dem Sudan.
Westliche Panzerwagen.
Ein versenktes Kriegsschiff.
Für die von den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten und Saudi-Arabien
angeführte Koalition
ist Mokka ein strategischer Punkt.
Es ist ihr Ausgangspunkt
zum Angriff auf al-Hudaida,
den wichtigsten Hafen des Landes.
Dieser liegt keine 200 km weiter
nördlich von Mokka, am Roten Meer.
Wir fahren durch die
erst kürzlich zurückeroberte Stadt.
Da uns die Kommandeure der Koalition
nicht empfangen wollen,
versuchen wir, einen
der lokalen Milizenführer zu treffen.
Doch auch hier
müssen wir erst einmal warten.
Die Kämpfer des Milizenführers
laden uns zum Mittagessen ein.
Reis mit Lamm,
das tägliche Essen an der Front.
Wo genau sind die Huthi?
Oh, die sind weit weg. 100 km.
* Stimmengewirr *
Dann taucht der Milizenführer
endlich auf.
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Abu Ahmad hat uns
gerade lange genug warten lassen,
um seine Macht zu demonstrieren, aber
er hat uns gleichzeitig bewirtet,
als Zeichen der Freundlichkeit.
Mit seinen Männern ist Abu Ahmad
für die innere Sicherheit
des Örtchens zuständig.
Mit Gottes Hilfe und dank Gott
werden die südjemenitischen
Widerstandskämpfer und unsere Armee
den Sieg davontragen.
Wir werden dies tun
mit der Hilfe der saudischen Armee
und dank der Männer aus den Emiraten
und von Abu Bin Zayid -
und dank der westlichen Koalition.
Es ist offensichtlich:
Abu Ahmad ist zwar der Chef in Mokka,
aber all seine Macht basiert
auf ausländischer Unterstützung.
Das macht den Krieg im Jemen
so kompliziert.
Die Huthi,
eine schiitische Widerstandsbewegung
aus dem Grenzgebiet zu Saudi-Arabien,
eroberten 2014 den Norden
mit der Hauptstadt Sanaa
und der Küste des Roten Meeres
und drangen schliesslich
bis nach Aden vor.
2015 griff eine von Saudi-Arabien
geführte arabische Allianz
aus zehn arabischen
und afrikanischen Ländern ein.
Mit loyalen jemenitischen Truppen
kontrollieren sie heute
den Süden und Osten des Landes.
Doch gleichzeitig
nutzen El Kaida, der IS
und andere Dschihadisten-Gruppen
das Chaos.
Zudem entstand eine neue starke süd-
jemenitische Separatistenbewegung.
Ein weiterer Kommandant trifft ein.
Komm her!
Abu Mohammad ist der Sicherheitschef
für die Umgebung von Mokka.
Mit Gottes Hilfe
kommen wir dem Sieg immer näher.
Die Jungs hier kämpfen stark,
und die Moral an der Front draussen
ist gut.
Wir haben schon viele Orte
von den Huthi befreit,
und wir werden
noch viele mehr befreien.
Wir rufen unsere Männer dazu auf,
diesen Siegeszug fortzusetzen.
Und wir rufen sie dazu auf, an die
Fronten zu strömen und zu siegen,
bis wir die Huthi, die unser Land
zerstört haben, ausgelöscht haben.
Abu Mohammad will uns etwas zeigen.
Geh in den anderen Wagen!
Abu Ahmad
soll mit deinem Wagen fahren.
Er ist der Verantwortliche
für dieses Gebiet.
Mokka ist strategisch wichtig.
Durch den Hafen hier
konnten die Huthi damals
alle ihre Waffen reinschmuggeln.
Waffen, die laut Abu Mohammad v.a.
aus dem Iran zu den Huthi gelangen.
Hinter den Huthi steht der Iran.
Der Iran und andere mit dem Iran
verbündete Gruppierungen
unterstützen die Huthi.
Es ist einfach für sie.
Es ist einfach, alles Mögliche
nach Jemen zu schmuggeln.
Denn auch wenn die Koalition
eine Seeblockade verhängt hat:
Wir haben viele kleine Häfen hier,
und die jemenitische Küste ist lang.
Sichere uns bitte da vorne ab!
Was ist?
Okay.
Falls die Huthi Frieden wollen,
müssen sie sich ergeben.
Sie haben keine andere Wahl.
Wir sind stark genug
und haben den Willen, zu kämpfen,
bis wir sie ausgelöscht haben
oder bis sie sich ergeben.
Davon scheint uns
die Militärallianz von Jemeniten,
Saudi-Arabien und Emiraten
allerdings weiter entfernt,
als uns dies Abu Mohammad
glauben machen will.
Auch wenn die Koalition hier
rund um Mokka die Lage im Griff hat
und Stärke demonstriert -
ein Ende des Krieges ist auch
nach drei Jahren nicht in Sicht.
Und schon jetzt ist abzusehen,
dass die lokalen Kommandeure
ihre neu gewonnenen Pfründe
auch nach einem Ende der Kämpfe
nicht einfach wieder aufgeben werden.
* Spannende arabische Musik *
Die wehrlosesten Opfer in einem Krieg
sind immer die Kinder. Auch im Jemen.
Und doch ist es hier noch schlimmer
als in den meisten anderen
Kriegsgebieten, in denen wir waren.
Das Schicksal des kleinen Mohammed,
dem unterernährten Baby
mit dem gespaltenen Gaumen,
geht uns nicht aus dem Kopf.
Wir fahren erneut
zum Al-Sadaqa-Spital.
Die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
sind selbst hier,
in einem öffentlichen Spital, rigide.
Jedenfalls mehr oder weniger.
Mohammed lebt,
aber er ist äusserst schwach.
Sein Zustand ist ernst. Sehr ernst.
Mohammed hat kaum Kraft -
nicht einmal zum Weinen.
Der Vater von Mohammed steht nebenan.
Seine Verzweiflung
ist mit Händen zu greifen.
Falls er genügend Gewicht erreicht,
kann er dann operiert werden?
Normalerweise muss er ein Jahr alt
sein für eine solche Operation.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
ist es sehr schwierig.
V.a. was den gespaltenen Gaumen
betrifft.
Sein Mund wird so bleiben,
bis er älter ist als ein Jahr?
Die Lippe,
das könnte man früher machen,
aber nicht, wenn er
drei Monate alt ist und 2 kg wiegt.
Ich habe gehört, diese Operation
könne man mit sechs Monaten machen.
Ja. Aber nicht, wenn ein Baby
2 kg wiegt. Wegen der Narkose.
Gründe für Mohammeds gespaltenen
Gaumen kann es viele geben.
Mangelernährung
und Stress der schwangeren Mutter
können erheblichen Einfluss haben.
Mohammeds Eltern
sind hilflos und überfordert.
Der Arzt sagte,
Mohammed gehe es besser.
Dass das nicht die Wahrheit ist,
spürt hier im Raum jeder.
Mein Sohn tut mir so leid.
Aber wir können nicht mehr tun,
als dem Schicksal vertrauen
und akzeptieren,
was Gott für uns entscheidet.
Als wir die Familie an diesem Abend
verlassen, glauben wir nicht mehr,
dass wir den kleinen Mohammed noch
einmal lebend wiedersehen werden.
* Energische arabische Musik *
Hier im Süden des Jemen,
in der Hafenstadt Aden,
hat die Koalition aus lokalen,
saudischen und emiratischen Truppen
die Huthi schon vor drei Jahren
aus der Stadt vertrieben.
Heute ist Aden
eine Mischung aus explosivem Kessel
und dem Versuch,
zur Normalität zurückzukehren.
Ich backe Brot.
Wir nennen es Chobbes.
Ist das die traditionelle Art?
Ja, es ist eine uralte Methode,
Brot zu backen.
Das grösste Problem
sind die ständig steigenden Preise.
Alles wird teurer und teurer.
Dabei fällt der Strom ständig aus,
und auch Wasser ist rar.
Das sind momentan
die grössten Probleme.
Solange es einigermassen sicher sei,
seien sie zufrieden,
sagen uns die Leute -
und laden uns zum Tee ein.
Hier im Zentrum von Aden
fühlt sich der Alltag an
wie in so manch anderer
arabischen Stadt auch.
Doch der Schein trügt.
Der international anerkannte
Präsident des Jemen, Mansur Hadi,
hat Aden zwar zu seiner
vorübergehenden Hauptstadt gemacht,
doch Hadi
lebt vorwiegend in Saudi-Arabien,
während sich in Aden
Warlords, Dschihadisten, Separatisten
und selbst die eigentlich Verbündeten
Saudi-Arabien und die Emirate
gegenseitig bekämpfen.
Der Krieg im Jemen ist hochkomplex.
Selbst die Einwohner
verstehen oft nicht,
wer nun genau gegen wen kämpft.
Ich versuche einfach,
meine Arbeit zu machen,
die Miete zu bezahlen
und die Stromrechnung.
Für alles andere
verlasse ich mich auf Gott.
Mohammed Mdenna presst Sesamöl.
Während des Krieges gegen die Huthi
verlief die Frontlinie
genau hier entlang,
direkt vor Mohammed Mdennas Geschäft.
Während des Krieges war die Lage
schon sehr brenzlig.
Ich habe jeweils nur eine Tür
geöffnet und den Leuten mein Öl
durch diese eine Türhälfte hindurch
verkauft.
Die Kugeln flogen vor meinem Laden
nur so herum. Huthi-Scharfschützen.
Zumindest diese Zeiten
sind in Aden inzwischen vorbei.
Wir reisen weiter,
hinaus aus der Stadt.
Hier beginnt schnell El-Kaida-Land.
Unsere Beschützer werden nervös.
Das Entführungsrisiko
wird hier grösser.
Auf dem Weg Richtung Norden:
immer wieder ausgebombte Häuser ...
... zerstörte Militärfahrzeuge.
Unser Ziel: ein Flüchtlingslager.
Wir haben schon viele Lager
in Kriegsgebieten gesehen,
aber so etwas noch nicht.
Zelte, die keine Zelte sind.
Hütten, die keine Hütten sind.
Ein paar vertrocknete Äste,
die zerrissene Planen zusammenhalten.
Diese Flüchtlinge gehören zu einer
der ärmsten Volksgruppen im Jemen.
Sie haben gar nichts mehr.
Die Frauen und Mädchen schützen
ihre Gesichter mit purem Lehm
gegen Sonne, Sand und Hitze.
Mehr als 2'000 Menschen
teilen sich eine einzige Toilette.
Es gibt keine medizinische
Versorgung, keinen Strom.
Die beiden einzigen Wassertanks
sind leck.
Ein Spielplatz für die Kinder
oder gar eine Schule: inexistent.
Hilfe kommt hier fast keine an -
zu gefährlich, zu abgelegen.
Wir werden
auf eine junge Frau aufmerksam,
die regungslos am Boden sitzt.
Leali ist 20 Jahre alt
und gelähmt seit dem Tag,
als die Kampfjets kamen.
Ich habe geschlafen,
als die Bomben fielen.
Die Mauer unseres Hauses
stürzte direkt auf mich.
Ich habe nichts gespürt,
ich hörte nur meine Mutter schreien:
"Meine Kinder!"
Ich wusste nicht, was los war,
aber als ich aufstehen wollte,
konnte ich
meine Beine nicht mehr bewegen.
Leali und ihre Familie
kommen aus Taizz.
Das ist jene Stadt
im Zentrum des Landes,
in der der Krieg
besonders heftig wütet.
Weisst du, wer weshalb
gegen wen kämpft in diesem Krieg?
Wir haben diesen Krieg
wegen der Huthi, sagen sie.
Die Mutter von Leali
erinnert sich genau an die Nacht,
in der die Bomben fielen:
Die Nachbarn kamen angerannt,
um zu helfen.
Sie brachten uns zu einem Spital,
aber der Arzt verlangte Geld
und ich hatte keins.
Also brachten wir Leali
zu einem anderen Arzt,
aber der konnte
nicht wirklich was für sie tun.
Deshalb kann sie jetzt
nicht mehr gehen.
Ein Mühlstein ist das Einzige, was
Safi Ahmad aus Taizz mitgebracht hat.
Es ist hart hier.
Wir haben kein Wasser, um zu putzen,
es gibt keine Toiletten, kein Bad.
Auch Trinkwasser gibt es kaum,
und es wird immer heisser.
Im Durchschnitt erkranken täglich
5'000 Jemeniten an Cholera.
Alle 10 Min. stirbt ein Kind
aus vermeidbaren Gründen.
Gemäss dem unabhängigen Netzwerk
Yemen Data Project
gilt nur ein Drittel
der saudischen Luftangriffe
jeweils gesichert
militärischen Zielen.
Der Rest trifft unschuldige Menschen.
Kinder wie den achtjährigen Ahmad.
Da kam ein Flugzeug.
Es warf eine Bombe ab.
Die Splitter haben ihn getroffen.
* Ein Kind weint. *
Die Bombe
riss ihm den Arm und das Bein weg.
Das sind zwei Prothesen.
Der Arm wurde von hier abgerissen,
das Bein ab hier.
Der Blick des Jungen
ist für uns fast nicht auszuhalten.
Was ist genau geschehen?
Ich habe Schafe gehütet,
und eine Rakete hat mich getroffen.
Das ist geschehen?
Ja. Woher die Rakete kam,
weiss ich nicht.
Geschichten wie diejenige von Ahmad
hören wir in jeder einzelnen
dieser Zelthütten.
Die Menschen, die hier
gestrandet sind, haben nichts mehr.
Keine Heimat,
keinen Besitz, keine Zukunft.
Auch der sechsjährigen Sahar
hilft niemand.
Sahar wurde
von einem Querschläger getroffen.
Sahar hat eine Kugel im Genick.
Sie steckt immer noch drin.
Wir können sie nicht rausnehmen.
Auf dem Röntgenbild
ist die Kugel deutlich zu sehen.
Sahar selbst sagt kein Wort.
Doch aus ihren Augen spricht Zorn.
Zorn über das,
was die Welt ihr angetan hat,
und über das,
was hier kaum einer versteht.
Wir haben keine Ahnung,
wofür dieser Krieg gut sein soll.
Wir wissen nur:
Unsere Häuser brennen,
Bomben treffen uns. Das ist alles.
Über 10'000 Tote
hat dieser Krieg bisher gefordert.
Mehr als 2 Mio. Menschen wurden
zu Flüchtlingen im eigenen Land.
Die UNO nennt den Krieg im Jemen
"die schlimmste
humanitäre Katastrophe des 21. Jh.".
Der Krieg hat Jemen so zerstört und
in die Armut gebombt, dass das Land
mit sämtlichen Grundbedürfnissen
versorgt werden muss.
Doch Nahrungsmittel, Wasser, Elek-
trizität, Treibstoff oder Medikamente
gelangen kaum ins Land.
Wir fahren zur Küstenwache in Aden.
* Erregte arabische Klänge *
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Oberst Marwan el-Bakshi
nimmt uns mit auf Patrouillenfahrt.
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Oberst Bakshi hat gerade noch
zwei kleine, seetüchtige Boote.
Er fährt uns an Wracks vorbei.
Das waren seine Schiffe,
mit denen die Küstenwache
früher patrouillierte.
Während der Schlacht um Aden
haben die Huthi sie versenkt.
Das da ist der Zollfrei-Hafen
mit dem Container-Deck.
Dort drüben ist der Ma'alla-Hafen.
Der Hafen, durch den eigentlich
Güter ins Land gelangen sollten.
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Aber interne Konflikte
verhindern das.
Manchmal kommt ein Schiff
mit Hilfsgütern,
mit Medikamenten
oder Nahrungsmitteln.
Wir dürfen es aber nicht reinlassen,
weil die Hafenleitung
diese Bewilligung erteilen muss.
Es sind diese kleinen Kriege
innerhalb des grossen Krieges,
die auch dazu führen, dass
Hilfslieferungen blockiert werden.
Hier in Aden streiten sich sogar
die beiden Verbündeten
Saudi-Arabien und
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
um die Vorherrschaft.
Die beiden blockieren sich.
Vor dem Krieg, vor 2015, waren wir
verantwortlich für den Hafen hier.
Aber seitdem Krieg herrscht,
kontrollieren andere Kräfte
den Hafen.
Arbeitet ihr zusammen
oder ist es eher schwierig?
Eher Letzteres.
Sagen wir es so:
Diese Leute sind nicht gut darin,
einen Hafen wie Ma'alla zu sichern.
Sie sind keine Spezialisten.
Deutlichere Worte kann ein Oberst
der jemenitischen Küstenwache
nicht wählen,
wenn er gefahrlos ausdrücken will,
dass er dem Muskelspiel
zwischen Saudi-Arabien
und den Emiraten
machtlos ausgeliefert ist.
Ein Muskelspiel, das dazu führt,
dass die wenigen Hilfslieferungen,
die überhaupt noch kommen,
manchmal monatelang im Hafen liegen
bleiben, bis die Ware verdorben ist.
Die Zerstörung im Jemen ist immens.
Seit Beginn des Krieges
führte die von Saudi-Arabien
angeführte Koalition
fast 17'000 Luftschläge durch.
Die Bomben treffen dabei
längst nicht nur militärische Ziele.
Diese Tür hat schon lange
niemand mehr geöffnet.
Dabei strömte durch diese Tür
früher täglich
eine ganze Horde Jugendlicher.
Es ist das Tor
zum Gymnasium von Wahd,
einem kleinen Ort rund eine
Autostunde ausserhalb von Aden.
Auch Zain al-Saqaf
ging hier zur Schule.
Es waren zwei. Zwei Bomben.
Eine hier und die andere dort.
Die Schule wurde bombardiert,
weil sich Huthi-Kämpfer
hier einquartiert hatten.
Was ist das hier?
Das ist die Uniform
eines der Getöteten.
Die Huthi waren hier,
der Luftschlag galt ihnen.
Weisst du, wie viele Menschen
bei dem Luftschlag getötet wurden?
Ich glaube, es waren drei.
Drei Huthi.
Du willst es nicht berühren,
nicht wahr?
Nein.
Da klebt immer noch Blut dran.
Alles liegt noch so da wie nach
jenem Tag, als die Bomben fielen.
Ich glaube ...
Das ist ein System von ...
von Pflanzen, denke ich.
Wie viele andere Menschen im Jemen
ist Zain wütend auf Saudi-Arabien.
Die Saudis sollen wenigstens
unsere Schule wiederaufbauen.
Sie haben sie zerstört,
also sollen sie sie wiederaufbauen.
Das war
unser ehemaliges Klassenzimmer.
Alles zerstört.
Wo hast du gesessen?
- Wie?
Das da, das war mein Platz.
Zain hat zu Hause weitergelernt
und studiert heute in Aden Medizin.
Viele seiner Mitschüler
haben das nicht geschafft.
Bis jetzt haben wir noch keinerlei
Wiederaufbauhilfe erhalten.
Schule hält hier keiner mehr.
Das schlägt sich
auf unsere Bildung nieder.
Andere können zur Schule gehen,
wir haben keine Schulen mehr.
Laut Yemen Data Project,
einem Projekt jemenitischer
Aktivisten, die versuchen,
Licht ins Dunkel des weitgehend
unbeachteten Krieges zu bringen,
hat die saudisch geführte
Militärallianz
seit Beginn des Krieges vor
drei Jahren 241 Schulen bombardiert.
241 Schulen!
Als wir den Ort verlassen,
begegnet uns diese Szenerie,
die ziemlich exakt zusammenfasst,
was im Jemen gerade geschieht:
Der Jemen war schon vor diesem Krieg
das ärmste Land der arabischen Welt.
Jetzt bomben modernste,
auch westliche Waffen
das Land und sein Bildungswesen
noch weiter zurück
in der Entwicklung.
Wir besuchen noch einmal
den kleinen Mohammed
und sind überrascht,
dass wir ihn und seine Mutter Sana
in einem anderen Zimmer vorfinden.
Vielleicht auch, weil sich unsere
Besuche herumgesprochen haben,
durfte Mohammed in eines der
vier Betten auf der Intensivstation.
Gestern war er extrem müde.
Er bekam keine Luft mehr.
Nach 6 Std.
gaben sie ihm endlich Sauerstoff.
Die Behandlung
hat offenbar etwas geholfen.
Seit heute Nachmittag
geht es ihm spürbar besser.
Die Leiterin der Intensivstation
ist ebenfalls erleichtert.
Was können Sie hier
mehr für ihn tun?
Das Erste ist, dass in diesem Raum
nur vier Patienten sind.
Dann ist immer eine Krankenschwester
hier, rund um die Uhr.
Er wird also immer überwacht.
Dazu hat er
permanente Sauerstoffversorgung.
Wenige Tage zuvor
hatten nicht nur wir den Eindruck,
dass der kleine Mohammed bereit war,
zu sterben.
Doch heute spüren wir neuen Lebens-
willen in seinem kleinen Körper.
Er ist deutlich weniger gestresst
als zuvor.
Er akzeptiert Nahrung,
das Fieber ist gesunken,
er ist weniger angespannt.
Er reagiert auf uns.
Es geht ihm also besser?
- Ja.
Wird er überleben?
- So Gott will.
Wir hoffen es.
Es wäre ein Leben
gegen alle Widerstände.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Am Hafen von Aden finden wir die
Reste des historischen Eingangstores.
Während der Kämpfe in der Stadt
wurden hier 43 Menschen getötet,
die Schutz gesucht hatten.
In den Trümmern
sitzt ein junger Mann.
Der Jemen ist verelendet, verwüstet,
ein hoffnungsloser Fall.
Mohammed Rashed hatte Pläne,
aber keine Chancen:
Ich finde keine Worte, um zu
beschreiben, was das mit dir macht.
Das Leben ist einfach nur
eine riesige Enttäuschung.
Was auch immer du dir
für Pläne ausdenkst,
du wirst enttäuscht,
drehst dich im Kreis,
in einem leeren Kreis.
Das ist die beste Beschreibung:
Du bewegst dich im Vakuum,
im Nichts.
Im Westen wäre Mohammed Rashed
ein begehrter Mann.
Er ist Englischlehrer
und Politologe.
Doch der Krieg
hat die wirtschaftliche Krise
und die Korruption
dramatisch verschärft.
Ich habe nichts.
Alles, was ich mache:
Ich schlage meine Zeit tot.
Ich verschwende meine Zeit,
und wenn du
deine Zeit verschwendest,
verschwendest du auch dein Leben,
denn Zeit bedeutet Leben.
So wie Mohammed Rashed geht es
Tausenden von jungen Jemeniten.
Doch flüchten können die wenigsten:
Die Grenzen zu Saudi-Arabien
sind abgeriegelt,
und auf der anderen Seite des Meeres
liegt Somalia.
Wir verlassen den Hafen
und tauchen ein in ein Aden,
wie wir es nicht erwartet hätten:
* Fröhliche, energische Musik *
Aden lebt - und wie!
* Jubelrufe und lauter Gesang *
Wir finden uns wieder auf einem Fest,
das eine Mischung ist
aus "MusicStar", Talentshow,
Stand-up-Comedy
und ganz einfach
einer riesigen Party.
Das örtliche Fernsehen
berichtet live,
und wären nicht überall
bewaffnete Wachen,
man könnte glatt vergessen,
wo man ist.
Höhepunkt des Abends ist der Auftritt
eines der bekanntesten Stand-up-
Comedians Adens: Mohammed el-Eryiany.
Wegen ihm sind wir hier.
Ich komme zu spät, ich weiss.
Aber vorher waren Regierungsleute
hier. Zur Hölle mit ihnen.
Komiker Eryiany
spielt eine alte Frau,
eine Figur, die hier so bekannt ist
wie in der Schweiz Harry Hasler
oder Emil.
Durch den Mund der alten Frau
kann Eryiany aussprechen,
was er sonst
nicht aussprechen könnte.
Ich muss mal über euch sprechen,
liebe Frauen.
Über eure Mode.
So viele verschiedene Abayas,
das ist ja Wahnsinn!
Ihr Girls seht aus
wie Weihnachtsbäume.
So viel Glitter und Glimmer von oben
bis unten und von hinten bis vorne.
Selbst die in - selbstverständlich
meistens schwarzen -
Abayas gekleideten Frauen
finden es lustig.
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Doch das gilt nicht für alle in Aden.
Der Komiker lebt gefährlich.
Normalerweise sage ich,
was ich will.
Auch wenn gerade wieder
ein paar Leute versucht haben,
mich umzubringen.
Ich sass mit vier Freunden
in einem Auto,
und wir wurden
mit fünf Schüssen beschossen.
Andere Leute haben mich angerufen
und gesagt,
sie seien vom IS oder von El Kaida,
und sie würden mich töten,
wenn ich nicht aufhören würde.
Ich habe ihnen gesagt,
dass ich weitermache,
auch wenn sie versuchen würden,
mich umzubringen.
Eine Fernsehshow mit Eryiany
wurde abgesetzt.
Die TV-Bosse waren
mit seinen kritischen Kommentaren
nicht einverstanden.
Es gibt so viele Probleme
in meinem Land.
Ich benutze diese Figur, aber ei-
gentlich spreche ich nur als Bürger.
Ich sage, was ich als Bürger
von meiner Regierung will.
Ich will Strom,
ich will fliessend Wasser,
ich will ein funktionierendes
Telefon, ganz alltägliche Sachen.
Das versuche ich
durch meine Figur zu sagen,
wenn ich auf der Bühne stehe.
Die Regierenden kritisiere ich,
weil die meistens
nur im Ausland leben,
von dort Befehle erteilen
und nicht betroffen sind von dem,
was wir hier zu spüren bekommen.
Wir treffen erneut Faisal und Sana.
Drei Monate
sind inzwischen vergangen.
Sie tragen Mohammed zum Flughafen.
Dank viel Hilfe von aussen kann die
Familie nun nach Jordanien fliegen.
In Amman kann der nun sechs Monate
alte Mohammed die Hilfe erhalten,
die er im Jemen nicht bekommen kann
und ohne die er sterben würde.
Wie heisst dieses Quartier?
Simsani.
Simsani?
- Ja. Seid ihr neu hier?
Ja, wir sind das erste Mal hier.
Im Taxi erzählt Faisal,
was seit unserem letzten Besuch
in seiner Heimat passiert ist:
In dem Spital,
in dem Mohammed zuletzt war,
hat ein Soldat
einen Arzt angegriffen.
Daraufhin trat das gesamte Spital
für zwei Monate in einen Streik.
Was geschah mit den Kindern?
Die anderen Kinder, die mit Mohammed
auf der Intensivstation lagen,
sind alle gestorben.
Alle ausser Mohammed
sind gestorben.
Mohammed erhält dank der Hilfe
einer kuwaitischen NGO
eine Chance zum Leben.
Die Organisation
kommt für die Operation in Amman auf.
* Mohammed schreit. *
Wael Sinnokrot ist der Kinderarzt,
der alles eingefädelt hat.
Er sieht den kleinen Mohammed
nun zum ersten Mal - und erschrickt.
Es sieht nicht gut aus.
Die aus Aden haben uns gesagt,
Mohammed wiege 5,5 kg.
Jetzt sehen wir: Er wiegt nur 4 kg.
Damit ist Mohammed eigentlich
viel zu leicht
für eine solch schwere Operation.
Für den Kleinen und seine Eltern
beginnt ein langer Tag
mit einer Untersuchung
nach der anderen.
* Mohammed weint laut. *
Das Fieber steigt,
sein Kopf ist heiss.
Mohammed soll geröntgt werden.
Denn er hatte in seinem kurzen Leben
schon mehrere Lungeninfektionen.
Diese konnten wegen
des Medikamentenmangels im Jemen
nicht angemessen behandelt werden.
* Mohammed weint. *
Und auch jetzt entdecken die Ärzte
eine entzündete Lunge.
* Keuchen *
Mein Kleiner, wie geht es dir?
Mein Leben, meine Seele, mein Herz.
Was haben sie mit dir gemacht?
Die Ärzte beraten, was zu tun ist.
Der Narkosearzt hat grosse Bedenken.
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
Es kann sein, dass er aufwacht,
und alles ist okay.
Aber es kann auch sein,
dass wir ihn eine Zeit lang
künstlich beatmen müssen.
Das können 2 Std. sein,
ein Tag, zwei Tage,
und es kann auch sein, Gott behüte,
dass es nicht gut ausgeht.
Verstehen Sie? Er kann sterben.
Wie gross ist dieses Risiko?
Das weiss niemand.
Es kann sein, dass er aufwacht
und alles ist gut.
Aber es kann auch sein,
dass er nicht mehr aufwacht.
* Keuchen *
Für die Eltern
bricht eine Welt zusammen.
* Mohammed weint. *
Am nächsten Morgen
soll die Operation stattfinden.
Doch die Ärzte
entscheiden sich dagegen.
Mohammed hatte über Nacht
hohes Fieber, dazu Durchfall
und Mühe, zu atmen.
Die Situation ist die:
Da Mohammed so hohes Fieber hat,
können wir ihn nicht
in Narkose setzen.
Wir wollen auch,
dass er besser atmet.
Ich werde euch Medikamente geben.
Die Operation
wird erst einmal verschoben.
Das Fieber macht uns Sorgen.
Wir wissen nicht,
ob es mit Mohammeds Atmungsproblemen
zusammenhängt.
Er hat einen Ausschlag
auf der Brust.
Oder mit dem Magen-Darm-Infekt,
den er entwickelt hat.
Wir müssen abwarten.
Er hat Fieber.
Aber seine Stimme ist lauter heute.
Er atmet besser.
In der Nacht konnte er kaum atmen.
Er keuchte.
Er hat um Atem gerungen.
Heute geht es ihm besser.
Fast schon wie immer.
Er ist viel ruhiger.
* Keuchen *
* Sie spricht arabisch. *
Viel Zeit hat Mohammed nicht.
Faisal und Sana
können nicht ewig in Amman bleiben.
Wenn die Operation
nicht bald stattfindet,
müssen sie zurück in den Jemen,
ohne dass Mohammed
geholfen werden konnte.
Es wird eine schwere Nacht.
Der dritte Tag
beginnt mit einer Überraschung:
Sana und Faisal
bringen Mohammed zum Operationssaal.
Das Fieber ist über Nacht gesunken.
Der Atem geht regelmässiger.
Deshalb haben die Ärzte beschlossen,
dass Mohammed heute
operiert werden soll.
Wie heisst er?
- Mohammed.
Mohammed.
Okay, auf Wiedersehen.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Alles wird gut, so Gott will.
Refat al-Sakeji ist einer der
besten Chirurgen in ganz Jordanien.
Er ist spezialisiert
auf Fälle wie Mohammed.
Mohammed
ist ein ganz schwieriger Fall.
Für die Wiederherstellung,
aber auch für den Narkosearzt.
Er wiegt viel zu wenig,
sein ganzer Zustand ist schlecht.
Die Operation
ist tatsächlich schwierig.
3 Std. später.
Die Operation ist vorbei,
Mohammed sollte aufwachen.
Und tatsächlich, der kleine Junge
öffnet seine Augen.
Ich hatte solche Angst um ihn.
Ich habe mir solche Sorgen gemacht.
Jetzt geht es mir so viel besser.
Der kleine Mohammed
hat es vorerst geschafft.
In sechs Monaten wird er wieder
operiert, dann wohl in Kuwait.
In ein, zwei Tagen
wird er wieder in den Jemen reisen.
Jemen ist kein guter Ort für Kinder.
Alles ist zerstört.
Die ganze Situation,
die Krankheiten.
Auch die Schulen: kaputt!
Dieser Krieg
hat alles zunichtegemacht.
Komplett zunichtegemacht.
Für den kleinen Mohammed
gibt es zumindest so etwas
wie einen kleinen Hoffnungsschimmer.
Der Krieg im Jemen
zerstört Leben, Hoffnungen, Träume.
Eine Lösung ist weit entfernt.
Die Menschen, die wir auf
unserer Reise kennengelernt haben,
kämpfen um ihr Leben, ihre Zukunft,
gegen den Zerfall.
Ich will den Jemen wiederaufbauen.
Jedes Kind in diesem Land
soll Hoffnung haben können.
Deshalb will ich es wiederaufbauen
und mithelfen,
dass etwas entsteht,
das so schön ist wie Amerika,
wie die Türkei,
wie die Länder in Europa.
Noor ist zwölf
und will Architektin werden.
Sie und ihre Familie sind unsere
letzte Begegnung hier in Aden.
Ich will meine Träume nicht aufgeben
wegen dem Krieg.
Ich werde mein Land wiederaufbauen
und die Hürden überwinden.
Was auch immer es braucht.
Ich werde mein Land wiederaufbauen.
Zum Abschied
singt Noor für uns ein Lied.
Es ist eine Liebeserklärung
ans Heimatland.
* Sanftes Lied: "Ya Blady"
von Ramy Gamal *